here's one of those a broken clock is
right twice a day sort of moments
brazen fox news propagandist sean
hannity
scolded missouri partiers for not
wearing masks on memorial day
and seemed to be defending george floyd
who was killed tragically by police
recently a story that has gone viral
let's take a look at a couple of clips
here's sean hannity
just seeming to make sense on the topic
of partiers massing together on memorial
day without wearing masks take a look
corey lake of the ozarks packed with
party goers
this holiday weekend look i understand
these are young people
experts keep saying over and over
they're at a much lower risk
but if they do get this and again
there's no
mask wearing here that i see and not
much at all i see no social distancing
but if they get the virus and that are
in contact with older and more
vulnerable americans
that could be a disaster for others
that's why in a short period of time
it's only temporary
you can't social distance please wear
the mask too for your mom your dad your
grandma your grandpa
my humble advice you don't have to
listen to me i'm not a doctor
now i wish hannity had said i'm not a
doctor
in his segment about hydroxychloroquine
a few weeks ago talking about a
prophylactic
regimen of hydroxychloroquine but he is
right
this is temporary we're all in it
together if you're in a large crowd if
you're close to people just wear a mask
let's get through this together help out
your fellow humans
part of why it's so surprising that
hannity is saying this is that he's been
a locus of misinformation and
disinformation propaganda
since the beginning of the coronavirus
pandemic it's not just his
hydroxychloroquine cocktail recipes that
he gave out
hannity has been insisting that trump
had the quickest and best response to
the virus that's a laughable joke
hannity was arguing for a while that
coronavirus was less of a threat
than the seasonal flu even in mid-march
hannity was still citing seasonal flu
numbers as this
completely meaningless comparison to a
novel coronavirus now
at the same time for a while
the same people who are now saying wear
a mask
were saying you don't need to wear a
mask now i have to tell you my position
on this has not changed
i'm still skeptical of the need to wear
a mask
outdoors when you're not near people if
you're outdoors right on top of people
if you're bunched together in a line for
a sustained period of time
if you were at an outdoor concert
certainly the more we know about the
virus the more we learn that the spread
is not really happening via surfaces
really as much
as at once at one point was feared it's
really person to person
the more we learn that the vast majority
is happening
indoors the more we learn about a
certain amount of viral load needing to
be transferred from one person to
another
for you to actually catch the the the
disease the virus to be infected
and often that requires 10 or 15 minutes
around someone not just passing them on
the bike path
but it doesn't really matter it doesn't
really matter you can look
at european countries just spoke to a
belgian friend who said
people aren't wearing masks outside in
belgium
but still hannity is talking about
people behaving irresponsibly partying
in large groups
together with no masks and the real
point is
the disregard for the lives of others
and so but listen
the hypocrisy of hannity does not go
ignored
the utility of masks in reality has not
actually changed
but if sean hannity is going to say this
and it might reach people in his
audience it's a good thing
one other hannity example here is
hannity yesterday
actually going after the police in the
george floyd
killing saying listen we're not doing
you know uh
trial by videotape but uh
i don't understand what cops did here it
doesn't make sense based on the video
i've seen and
any opportunity for sean hannity to brag
about his martial arts practice
he always takes advantage of take a look
and again this is not trial by
videotape here that has nothing to do
with it
this guy is not resisting on any video
we see
you hear him clear clearly saying i
can't breathe isn't i have to imagine
and i talked to but my martial arts
sensei
trains police officers for free he says
it is scary to him
how for most officers a lot of officers
their only option is what's on their
their sidearm
that's it or a stun gun they're not
trained
in the use of martial arts but even a
rudimentary trainee would say
would would you would know how sensitive
this is to one's neck
so very interesting sort of moments of
clarity on sean hannity's show
now there's one other angle it's a very
cynical angle which is that fox news is
increasingly afraid
of getting sued and though and so they
are starting to be a little more
cautious
about what they say regarding masks and
social distancing and the like
okay i don't get the sense that that's
what's affecting sean hannity's
day-to-day coverage and lastly remember
just because they say one or two things
that make sense
these are not our allies these are
people who profit from spreading lethal
disinformation for political gain
uh allying themselves with the president
and carrying water for donald trump
their priorities are
access to access rather said to
elites and politicians and profit
those are their priorities and you know
when they say the right thing will take
it
it might save a life it might change the
perspective of a fox news viewer
hey you know what maybe the police
weren't justified in killing
killing george floyd so we will take it
but
a future of critical thinking and
empiricism
is not going to be catalyzed by sean
hannity even if he says wear a mask for
grandma
but to the extent that he can challenge
the echo chamber of anybody in the fox
news audience
i'll take it and gladly so make sure
you're following the david pakman show
on
instagram at david pakman show we've got
polls we've got behind the scenes
pictures
we have all sorts of stuff and on my
instagram at david.pacman
uh people going crazy for my quarantine
before and after picture
i did a split on my instagram what i
looked like two and a half months ago
before the start of quarantine and what
i look like now
it's been a slow change i barely
recognize my own pre-quarantined self
check it out on instagram david.pakman
we will take a quick break
we've got some very exciting stuff
coming up later today on the program
nordvpn one of our sponsors is giving
you
70 off a three-year plan which is just a
little over three bucks a month
and you'll get an extra month free when
you go to nordvpn.com
david pakman or go to their website use
the coupon code
david pakman if you don't use a vpn
now is the time to start i always use a
vpn on my computer and my phone
it makes you totally anonymous when
you're browsing online you won't be
spied on
websites can't track you around the
internet your data is safe
from hackers and nordvpn is the one you
want to go with
because they don't keep records on your
internet history they double encrypt
your data
their servers are super fast and they
provide unlimited bandwidth
nordvpn is giving you seventy percent
off a three-year plan that's just over
three bucks a month
plus an extra month free when you go to
nordvpn.com
david pakman i've put a link right
underneath the video or just go to their
website and use the coupon code
david pakman